are you having cravings like that no I
have more versions like I don't like
chicken anymore that weirds me out right
wine right I mean I you can't drink and
you shouldn't drink I keep trying to
drink a lot of wine but now my eighth
month they're like oh you can have a you
can have a sip or a cup whatever and I
tasted my husband's of the day and I was
like wow what is that right it's just
horrible coffee I love coffee I hate
coffee I don't like the smell of it do
you like fast food are there any fast
foods you get you Wendy's Wendy's yeah
yeah I love not are ya
oh you think he just kicks yeah right
your joke I think oh I've heard at the
notion of Barbies yeah I know
no I okay you can you can let go that
was so tasty done it's like you were
taking a spider off with you so so you
you used to work at Wendy's right I used
to work at Wendy's yeah and it's so
funny because I put french fries in my
frosty like I eat my frosty with french
fries my girlfriend's like pregnancy and
a mic no this is me this is what you do
yeah what what you should do that's what
one must do what one must do why when
you're working at Wendy's you were
saving up money for so night for my
quinceanera quinceanera yeah because my
parents didn't want to throw me one
because they're very expensive
no no they're very cheap my family yeah
no it's very expensive and I have three
older sisters there's four girls and so
my mom was like your sisters didn't get
a continue no you're not getting aids
and Yetta so I snuck out and I got a job
at Wendy's and never told them and
raised the money for your own
quinceanera well no then my teacher
busted me cuz a teacher came in she was
like Eva and I was like no my mom found
out I was working like you know most
kids maybe are doing drugs and I'm like
I'm working you know you're hiding deep
shame a child has when they work at
Wendy's
yeah yeah I says you can't work into
your six and so yeah yeah I know you can
work if you had a parent permit oh and
you didn't you did well I faked it yeah
you know we have a picture of you at
your quinceanera mustache in that photo
you did not have this going so I looked
at my quinceañera
you